taxes
at least for me there's no more
unwelcome letter in the mailbox then
that plain white envelope with a little
window bearing the eagle the scales and
the olive branch of the Internal Revenue
Service let's wondered about the olive
branch I don't know what the olive
branch has to do with the scales I can
see because you feel like you're being
weighed when I get one I don't know if
you ever do this maybe it's just my
personality I tend to put it on the
kitchen counter and let it breathe for a
few days because I'm afraid to look at
it even if I have absolutely no reason
to believe that the news is bad still
because it says Internal Revenue Service
on it I am afraid of that envelope it's
worth talking about in church even
though the idea of talking about taxes
in church doesn't seem to make any sense
I mean what two things could be more
different than taxes and church nothing
to do with each other but what makes me
think about it is that most of us have
so few times when we worry about the
power of the state over us we just don't
think about well yes there are new haven
parking tickets but that's a whole other
thing but most of us have little reason
to fear the man in uniform knocking at
our door but somehow when that IRS
envelope arrives I can't help but
imagine how I might look in an orange
jumpsuit
taxes the unwelcome intrusion of the
state into my business my money as the
Tea Partiers say that intrusion with the
subtle implied threat of pay up or go to
jail I'm not going to talk about tax
policy today I can see yang is yawning
already tax policy nothing more boring
in the world but what I want to talk
about is this sign of power over me why
do I get afraid why not get afraid about
this envelope it's because I know these
people have absolute power over me and
it makes me think about the many parts
of my life that are actually governed by
other people and by forces that exert
tremendous influence on me but that I do
not include in my impression of myself i
do not see myself as a subject of the
Internal Revenue Service but clearly it
exerts great influence on me if I'm this
afraid of that envelope so it gets me
thinking about what else in my life is
exerting influence on me that changes me
that I don't even include in my picture
of myself perhaps my employer perhaps my
professor perhaps my crazy roommate what
else is it in my life that is changing
me without me knowing now imagine
yourself a citizen of a defeated country
subject to a ruthless and powerful
Empire where some far away Emperor
orders yet another tax on your land on
your person on your income and forced by
soldiers who seem to hate your culture
and your religion the threat of taxes
comes not in a clean white envelope in
the mail but comes with a sword Oh close
to your threat
what should a faithful person do pay
their taxes and support their own
oppression or resist and die this is the
question the Pharisees and the Herodians
come to Jesus with they say in their
most flattering tone you are an honest
man of Jesus you tell the truth no
matter what people think so tell us
should we pay taxes to caesar just like
the most inviting host on Fox News or
MSNBC gonna put you in a trap with an
unanswerable question if Jesus says yes
he's no Jewish prophet if he says no the
plot against him gains another weapon
his treason against the Empire so Jesus
doesn't answer instead he asks for the
coin used to pay the tax because it has
to be a special room and coin and he
says whose picture is on it whose image
and its opponents say Caesars the
Emperor's and Jesus says well then give
Caesar what bears his image but give God
what bears God's image you can imagine
the Pharisees as the gospel says
wandering away thinking what a weird and
possibly wise answer you know if which i
think is the way they feel about Jesus
most the time weird but possibly wise
but wait a minute he never really
answered that question never said should
we pay taxes or not Jesus won't be
trapped by flattering words he won't be
trapped by the desire to win an argument
he doesn't I think even really want to
set the Pharisees straight I think his
words are for the poor and the lost and
they are the ones who hear his message
the last three weeks of church we've
heard parables about loyalty the two
sons which will serve the father the
wedding guests will they respond to the
invitation who is truly loyal to God
how do we know and today following that
we get a practical test broad question
of loyalty how does it come down to
earth it's about taxes but it's really
about more than taxes it's about all the
ways that the world pulls us away from
God taxes themselves aren't evil they
are just one obligation one more force
acting upon us that we don't know what
to do with but taxes can seem so
unreligious so unchurched Lee that we
forget that those obligations do affect
our life of faith they have power over
us so I want you to imagine yourself as
a NASCAR driver okay you have a bright
jumpsuit and on it our patches of all
your sponsors we've ever seen a NASCAR
driver who must have a hundred patches
on him of all the companies that are
paying for him I wonder if he has them
dekalb on his teeth and things too I
don't know but I want you to imagine
what patches your jumpsuit would carry
who demands your loyalty and your time
what hey who are your sponsors who's
paying for you maybe academics maybe
success or security big patches that
takes a lot of our time and loyalty
certainly our families activities arts
and clubs and service and then there are
the things that really take our time
that we don't want to think about like
Facebook and video games and clothes and
food that really occupy more time than
we like to think and then the truly
hidden ones that really consume our
energy pointless worrying grudges
self-doubt self-pity and V of other
people
one of the best sermons I read on this
passage is by Judith Johnson see both
and she writes we want to do everything
rather than select some things to devote
ourselves to as the top priority and let
others go and we what we end up doing is
giving God the balance left over when
everything else has been accomplished
all the things were loyal to all the
labels we bear she quotes Thomas a Kelly
and my favorite one of my favorite books
called a testament of devotion he writes
we are trying to be several people at
the same time without all ourselves
being organized by a single mastering
life within us each of us tends to be
not a single self but whole committee of
cells and each of ourselves in turn is a
rank individualist not cooperating with
the other selves but shouting out there
their vote loudly for themselves when
voting time comes it is it is as if we
have a chairman of our committee of many
cells who does not integrate the many
into one but who merely counts the votes
at each decision and leave disgruntled
minorities we are not integrated we are
distraught we feel honestly the pull of
many obligations and we try to fulfill
them all but life is meant to be lived
from a center a divine center but most
of us I fear have not surrendered the
rest in order to discover the holy
within when pieces asks Pharisees whose
images on the coin the word for image is
the same word when translated into Greek
from Genesis 1 26 to 27 then God said
let us make human kind in our image
according to our likeness so God created
humankind in His image in the image of
God he created them male and female he
created them if we give to our
obligations to Caesar the coins that
bear their image what's left to give to
God only everything only our whole
selves which bear the image of God would
give that small image to Caesar what is
it that bears the image of God just all
of us and all of our lives perhaps it's
because the divine image we bear seem so
distant so instead we bear the image of
the pressures on us of the society that
made us of every demanding advertisement
we've ever watched of every obligation
we feel we need to bear perhaps it would
be easier to say no to these limitless
demands to give the fullness of our
lives to God if we realize that who we
are is not the things we imagine or fear
other people think we are who we are is
a holy people made the image of God my
fear often is that I will be a failure
unloved unrecognized unrewarded and that
fear is even more powerful than the fear
of the state even more powerful than the
fear of the IRS Jesus would have us
reverse our culture's formula that I
should live in fear of what I am NOT and
let that determine my priorities Jesus
says live in to what you are divinely
created love since the day of your birth
forgiven even the sins you can't forgive
yourself filled with god's spirit
destined for God's kingdom I am NOT an
empty vessel waiting to be filled
by life I am NOT a nameless cipher
waiting for achievement or relationship
to save me I am a child of God and on
that basis I am empowered to say no to
everything else that exerts power over
me I Know Who I am and I know whose I am
it's easy to forget in our secular
culture that there are fewer reminders
of obligation and faith than the young
men who gathered here a hundred and
fifty years ago had they had daily
required chapel and twice on Sunday
sometimes up to six hours of church
though many of them resisted and they
didn't their world was one where
Christian faith was presumed and the
world worked on a Christian basis
something look back on that world with
nostalgia but i prefer the world we have
where my Catholic or Jewish neighbors
have the same rights I do in particular
society however we have to work harder
at maintaining our priorities no time
will be set aside for us for faith it
will not be required we will not learn
the Bible in school we live in a world
where the easy presumption that
Protestant faith is normal is gone the
world we live in is I think still a
better world because when Christian
becomes normal it usually ceases to be
really Christian but I think the
temptation this world puts us in is to
make faith a hobby an unusual interest
that I happen to have like collecting
antiques or following the Chicago Cubs
something I could change maybe
something I do when nothing important is
happening the rest of the world will not
give us time for our faith we have to
fight for it the rest of the world won't
tell us what we believe we have to read
the scriptures for ourselves if we find
the time the time to remember in whose
image we were made in whose spirit we
live we can overthrow the tyranny of the
Caesars the many of them the false gods
of obligation and money and elitism and
beauty and success and power but I will
not leave you where Jesus left you
should we pay our taxes doesn't Jesus
finally care about injustice and
oppression yes he does but he knows we
pay much higher taxes to our own fears
and those thrust upon us that we do to
the Empire and only when we are free
from the taxes of desire can we truly
challenge Caesars order amen